do you feel hopeful with your parents
case especially now that their sentence
has been reduced slightly yes so their
sentence what a lot of people don't
necessarily understand what their
sentence is being reduced dads was
reduced by two years moms like 18 months
and that was all due to the first step
Act and the first step Act was it
actually introduced under the Trump
Administration and it was to give
incarcerated individuals a second chance
so there are classes that you can take
while you're in prison and you can do
all of these different things to help
better yourself to enter back into
society and so that's what that was was
just the classes that they're taking to
reduce their sentence and so that has
helped drastically but there's also huge
reform things that are coming down the
pipeline which is a huge two-point
reduction that in February will come
into effect which could very easily
reduce their sentences by a few years
each
um so it just depends on how it works
out but obviously we have an open appeal
that we're waiting to see what happens I
was going to ask what the status was
yeah so it's all been filed and now we
just sit and wait and then we have asked
for oral arguments the government
obviously has said we don't want World
arguments which you know that's now for
an appeals court to rule on so there's a
lot of different things in play that we
just now said wait how often are you
able to speak to your parents and see
that yeah so I speak to them multiple
times a day like they'll call me and
then I see them every weekend okay so
there has not been a weekend other than
like two or three weekends where I've
been working that I have not seen one of
them so I go back and forth which is
also not a sustainable lifestyle
um to just be like playing ping pong
between Florida and Kentucky but I do it
and it's so great seeing them because I
get to hug on them love on them like we
get to catch up on all the things you
said your dad's sporting a new look oh
yes Dad you know Dad is just he's such a
champ and I like to say like where he's
at I mean he has a great Barber and he
is hot as all get out he takes it in
strides like he's like I'm gonna do the
best that I can but also this experience
it's like if we can take this and make a
difference in other people's lives then
that's what we're willing to do I mean I
just got an email last night from
another man's son that's in there with
Dad talking about the mistreatment of
him and he was like can you please help
me do something about this and I look at
our whole situation I'm like that's why
this is happening like this is happening
so we can make a difference in millions
of lives even if it makes hours harder
along the way you have these men also
women where my mom's at to where you
have no air conditioning it can be 115
degrees inside your padlocking ice
machines you're not giving proper
Medical Care and they're doing nothing
about it and that's the hard part is
I've spoken out about it and obviously
there's been some retaliation here and
there between Mom and Dad which is
really sad because it's just like let's
speak out about the truth let's change
these people's lives it's so admirable
too because like you could take one of
two approaches you could just be like
I'm going in a corner I don't want to
talk to anybody but you're not you're
using this platform to now help others
who are going through tough times I've
had a lot of people come at me and say
oh well like you never cared about
prison reform before this whole thing
happened and it's just life we don't
care about anything really until it
affects us personally and then when it
affects us personally we're like oh I
had no idea that these things were
happening and now I'm in a place to
where I see people being mistreated and
I see it on a daily basis and my parents
and all these people involved and I'm
like all right I have a platform and now
that I know better it's my
responsibility to do better and also
like you're 26 years old yes that's what
strikes me the most is you are 26 years
old you're so young you are having to
step up in a way that most 26 year olds
don't ever see in their lifetime do you
feel like you have the weight of the
world on your shoulders you know I feel
like God never gives you more than you
can bear and I feel like what is
happening right now is exactly what I
needed to not be this like spoiled
entitled whatever because what's
happening now is it's testing who I am
as a person it took away a lot of things
I mean for about a year like anything
thing work wise disappeared meanwhile
the public has been grabbing on to every
little thing and they're like we want to
see it we want to see it and that's
where we partnered with Scout
Productions which we're doing a whole
new show just about everything happening
it's definitely tested me but helping to
be I like to call it like a bonus parent
for my siblings like it's been the
hardest but most rewarding job I will
ever have of course there's like a a
grieving process in the sense you know
losing your parents to prison there's
the anger the sadness but I feel like
you're on the other side closer to that
for sure I'm definitely I think the
hardest part was like the first holiday
with them leaving it was Grayson's
birthday Chloe's first day of school all
the firsts that happen
it's still a grieving process whether
they're passed away or not like they're
still not there we're kind of in the
groove of things so and luckily kids
have a way of turning like pain into
humor I mean Chloe poor kid I'm like she
has gone through so much like so many
traumatic experiences in her life but
she got in trouble at school because she
was talking and the teacher was like if
you keep talking like I'm gonna have to
email your parents and Chloe comes home
and she goes I thought to myself go
ahead and email them good luck getting a
response oh my gosh I died because I was
like that just goes to show how kids
turn like paper
it's gonna be a big drop hope you
prepare for this
what have you learned about
yourself on this show because you are
put through it mentally physically
emotionally all of it I thought I would
be like a rock star or something like
this but then when the emotion set in
and I remember sitting there and I was
like for once in my life I love two
people
more than I love myself which is Chloe
and Grayson and like being away from
them for so long it was like completely
ripping me apart I was like I was not
prepared for this to feel what I was
feeling so it was it was a tough
challenge it was more of a mental
challenge Than Physical for sure and in
those moments I imagine having a cast
that you grow close with yes served as a
huge help I mean I see you on social
media with Kelly Rizzo now yes I would
say the closest friendships that I made
were definitely JoJo Kelly Robert Ory I
will say forever I have so much love and
respect for him like he's like the Jolly
Green Giant like the sweetest our beds
were next to each other so like we laid
in bed at night after the lights went
off and talked and had like deep
heartfelt conversations and then Brian
Austin Green like just an angel and we
had some like even off camera he and I
had some tough conversations of just
like disagreeing but understanding where
each other was coming from and it just
made me realize that like as a society
that's where we all need to get to that
we can have like productive
conversations while believing in our own
values and beliefs it was just an
awesome overall experience
foreign